Masa amini seen here on the night she
died exiting a vehicle that belongs to
Iran's morality police
inside about half an hour later she
approaches a female officer and it looks
like they discuss what Masa is wearing
then she collapses
we won't show her fool to the ground but
it's believed that by the time these
paramedics came along Masa had already
died
Iranian officials dispute this
they also dispute what happened to
protester Nika shakarami who Iran's
police chief says fell to her death from
a high building
her face
bones and teeth were ruptured the back
of her head had been hit hard her skull
was deformed this is how she was killed
the damage was to her head
on the morning of her funeral they stole
her body and without telling any of us
they buried it in a remote Village Under
tight security conditions
the gulf between official versions of
events and what the wider public
believes has led to the gravest threat
to Iran's ruling Elites we've seen for
years in Iran and elsewhere the start
now of a fourth week of protests
fountains that run dry are painted red
for blood more than 150 people have been
killed in the unrest here since marsa's
death
[Applause]
these protests can bring about change
according to those of gathered here in
London today thousands of them who say
there will be a revolution the only time
and the last time so if people want to
make a difference this is the only time
I think the only chance that we have
will change happen of course 100 Maybe
not today maybe not tomorrow but it will
come this year's Evolution we are going
to be with them
women lead protests here as they have in
Iran the uprising they say already
showing signs of change
Saudia Chaudhary Sky News